[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
discussion que peuvent avoir le
président m'a cran avec eux hier le
chanceux les shops et puis le président
poutine n'avance pas d'après le
ministère de la santé ukrainien
63 hôpitaux ont été bombardés depuis le
début du conflit
aucun militaire riman présent poutine
est bloqué dans son maximalisme il est
bloqué dans ses objectifs de guerre il
n'en démord pas il agit sous la forme
d'un diktat hier épargner les zones
civiles sont aujourd'hui frappés
après les bombes
le chaos vidéo de propagande diffusé ces
derniers jours montrent également des
soldats tchétchènes et syriens en
partance pour l'ukraine des militaire
réputé sanglant capable des pires
exactions bien entendu il appartiendra à
ceux qui sont en charge de ce style se
sont et seront en charge de cette
justice a qualifié a qualifié sur v il
ya décider quelles sont les sanctions
qu'elles sont les punitions ni la russie
ni les états unis d'ailleurs un ne
reconnaissent la cour pénale
internationale
donc
encore une fois c'est la question s'est
il faut aller chercher à prévoyez parce
que c'est bien beau de condamner mais
bon on va pas à grand chose des milliers
de réfugiés convergent face aux
postes-frontières
17000 ce jour là
essentiellement des femmes et des
enfants de tous âges il faut évidemment
apporter toute l'aide humanitaire qu'il
est possible d'apporter aux ukrainiens
et qui passe évidemment par l'accueil de
réfugiés de guerre en france pour ceux
qui souhaitent venir c'est ce que nous
avons fait c'est ce que louis aliot a
fait à perpignan on voit déjà que
profitant de cette ouverture des
frontières il y à de nombreux algériens
africains qui en profitent pour venir en
france aussi qui passent les mailles du
filet selon lui près d'un tiers des
réfugiés ukrainien dix ukrainiens qui
arrivent en france ne sont en réalité
pas des ukrainiens et on ne doit pas les
éléphants son président abbas ils ne
sont pas eu craignant et qu'ils sont des
algériens des marocains
des africains comme semble-t-il le
révèlent nos confrères du figaro ils ont
vocation à aller en algérie pendant des
mois nous allons mener
une espèce de nouveaux grands débats
permanents pour agir dans dix ans sur
les choix les plus difficiles pour notre
pays ce avec vous eric zemmour n'a pas
l'habitude qu'on lui résiste et c'est un
débatteur extrêmement violent et il
pratique le j'allais dire le torrent de
boue donc ils envoient des torrents de
boue sur son
oui mais il n'était pas question que je
me laisse faire pendant plusieurs mois
pendant les cinq années qui suivent nous
allons président est gouvernée agir avec
vous dans la durée
alors le gouvernement a décidé d'agir à
l'entrée de la station l'automobiliste
verra toujours 2 euros 20 par litre par
exemple mais en payant avec sa carte
bancaire ou à la caisse il bénéficiera
d'une réduction de 15 centimes par litre
ça paraît quand même comme très
dérisoire et même du foutage de gueule
facile à dire mais c'est vrai que c'est
dès maintenant qu'il aurait fallu
prendre cette mesure le 1er avril on
voit bien que c'est peut-être dix jours
de l'élection c'est un petit peu la
ficelle est un peu grosse il aurait
fallu le faire dès maintenant et puis
pardon et un petit côté quand même un
peu clientéliste et électoralistes
puisqu'on nous explique que c'est même
pas le prix à la pompe mais ça va être
quand vous allez payer vous aurez à une
petite mention vous expliquant combien
le gouvernement nous a fait un cadeau
donc à l'évidence ça n'est pas à la
hauteur de la gravité de la situation
d'aujourd'hui est peut-être d'ailleurs
de demain c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je persiste à dire qu'il faut
baisser de manière pérenne la tva sur le
l'énergie de manière générale la
campagne de marine le pen ne tournant
quasiment qu'autour de ses chats elle a
trouvé ce truc pour se rendre synthèse
sympathique voilà parce que catwoman ça
aurait été parfait pour elle